let's go back to the audience on our
discord if you'd like to call in you can
go to davidpakman.com
discord
let's speak next to harrison from
california harrison you are on the air
welcome
hey david thanks for having me my
pleasure
um i didn't really come with a specific
question other than um just to share
uh frustration
not too long ago actually i think it was
the other night i watched a cliff of
yours uh where someone asked about how
your
girlfriend communicates with a
largely conservative family
and it resonated with me i have um both
my parents whom are separated uh have
over the past six years
been just completely inundated with
the conservative the typical
conservative talking points you know you
name it from fox news to uh
um you know tucker caller that carlson
to um you know my my mom who's always
been more
conservative
but
she has
turned into like she's just gone
straight down the rabbit hole to the
point where
you know she sends me stuff and she's on
like telegram with these
uh q and on people and i'm just like
i try to say like look
you need to get rid of this she there's
no ability she has no ability to tell
right from wrong and i mean the most
ironic thing is when i bring
counterpoints up she gives my points
more scrutiny and criticism than
the points that other people are telling
her she just like accepts you know it's
typical i expect it accepting the things
that agree with her and you know things
that she doesn't agree with hey let me
ask you this what what kind of what
field does she work in
um
she's she's been in sales a lot but uh
she's like a
like in kind of like the
real estate kind of thing right now it
does she seem to have an ability to
think critically in within the field of
real
estate in other words when people make
claims about
oh look it looks like you've got a
termite damage uh no no no no we don't
it's fine that's actually nothing she
like is she's able to discern that like
people might be lying there or is does
she generally is she generally naive
uh generally generally not i mean it's
more of a like happy-go-lucky person and
i mean it's worked for you know she's a
kind-hearted person like in reality but
the one thing is you know she's uh
like a little bit of her background her
and her family my my uh
parents and aunts and uncles
grandparents ran away from communism uh
in from china
um and it for so for that reason their
whole journey to get to america back you
know in the 50s and 60s like 50s and 60s
um really you know is what got them
really patriotic and and really
appreciate the country which is
something that
when i was growing up really you know
made me kind of proud and
and uh
you know stuff like that but it always
gave
you know my my family's pretty split so
half of it is a little more liberal half
per half is a little more conservative
and um
she like she does exhibit
a little bit of
like critical thinking when it matters
but i mean
at the same time like i couldn't you
know if she went to take her car and to
get fixed like
should probably get ripped off to tell
you to be the truth like i'm usually
have to be the one to be like okay wait
wait like does this actually need to
happen i can actually do this so
it sounds like maybe there's just the
personality predisposition to sort of
accept what people are saying in some
way and it's not just on politics
yeah there there is a predisposition and
that's why i feel like she's more
of a victim of the
the whole you know narrative that
they're trying to pitch because she's
definitely someone when i was growing up
you know the am radio is always on
always talking to like uh rush limbaugh
or like listening to all these shows
yeah and she would come home from work
and like the first things out of her
mouth was just you know oh my god
obama's gonna do this you know uh
this and that that little you know
they're gonna try and take over the
country and like it's it's not that bad
it's i've literally been sitting through
30 years
of the skies falling essentially about
you know
liberalism and i i was in the marine
corps for for seven years and so i you
know i get the the concern you know
patriotic conservative standing
standpoints and just only really over
the past like five years
have i really just kind of turned and
been like you know that there's really
nothing
that
you know
insane that's happening
on this side like this there are like
crazy ideas but there's crazy ideas on
both sides and the stuff that ends up
getting executed and assigned into
action
really are pretty mild at the end of the
day hey in the in the marine corps were
were there any progressives or was it
very very conservative
it's it's largely conservative
absolutely um there are like i i've met
quite a few
like rational level-headed people they
might still fall on the conservative
spectrum and
um
but there there definitely are like
i mean it's probably i would say some of
the best people i've met
have been the ones that have ended up
being a little more like moderate to
to liberal like in political view and
that's not just by like me asking them
like hey what are you but it's just
their personality showed it which is
what you know why we became great
friends and then later on i was like oh
hey like you know after getting to know
them like hey he's actually kind of
you know rational thinking in the
military but it's definitely a minority
well harrison you've really said it all
i i appreciate it sounds like a
complicated situation but i wish you the
best
i appreciate you taking the time to talk
to me all right harrison from california
that's quite a scene that's for sure i
would not uh
that that's complicated